tausende Menschen feiern auf Mallorca
aber nicht am Ballermann sondern so
feiert Mallorca Weihnachten auf der
Baleareninsel feiern die Menschen das
Weihnachtsfest traditionell in der Nacht
zum Dreikönigstag mit einem gigantischen
Festumzug und das trotz Corona es
herrscht fröhliche Partystimmung auf
Mallorca die heiligen drei Könige ziehen
überall durch Mallorcas Dörfer von
zahlreichen geschmückten Festwagen
werfen sie Süßigkeiten in ihrer in der
Zuschauer das ganze erinnert stark an
die deutschen Karnevalsumzüge mit den
Unterschied dass sie sich hierbei um die
Karawane aus dem Morgenland handeln soll
trotz der corona-pandemie nehmen ganze
Menschenmassen an der Prozession Teil
die Inzidenz auf Mallorca aktuell über
doch auch trotz der corona-pandemie ist
es für die Kinder wieder das Highlight
zum Jahresbeginn 2022